[Music]
data zoo is a digital marketing
management company we have three major
functions we manage data for our
customers and join that data across
their multiple devices to provide a
singular view of that customer we call
that one view we have our insights
platform that we take that data and turn
it into usable insights and analytics by
applying machine learning and AI the
third part is the most exciting part
where we we call action data inside an
action where we automatically optimize
and rebalance media portfolios based on
what we learned from the data data sue
built its platform on top of the IBM
bluemix cloud we looked at the other
cloud vendors and we found that IBM was
able to offer very high-end CPUs on a
very low latency network that's
important because we're observing on a
global basis 25 billion digital touch
points every day and we have to make
three million decisions a second the
latency of under 10 milliseconds for
each one we found from a price
performance point of view only the IBM
cloud could provide that for us we
heavily leveraged IBM's bare-metal cloud
offering it's very unique one in the
marketplace we're also using other API
driven services such as the what Watson
cognitive services it's a way that we
can leverage the kinds of customer
insights that Watson generates and use
it to further increase the marketing ROI
driven by our platform iBM has been a
strong partner that has provided
in-depth analyses to help us optimize
our deployments on global basis it's
made us the most efficient technology
platform in our space